اعتقل اللاعب التونسي رئيس كتله الائتلاف
الكرامه سيف الدين مخلوف بعد احكام للقضاء
العسكري بسجن عدد من قيادات الائتلاف
وشخصيات اخرى على خلفيه ما تعرف بقضيه
المطار وبين ما وصف جبهه خلاص الاحكام
بالانتقاميه رافضه محاكمه المدنيين امام
القضاء العسكريين شدد رئيس قيس سعيد على
التصدي لمن وصفهم بكونهم يعتقدون انهم فوق
القانون
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولدنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات في اي سياق صدرت احكام
بالسجن على شخصيه سياسيه وحقوقيه من قبل
القضائي العسكريه ثم التداعيات القانونيه
والسياسيه لهذه المحاكمات العسكريه على
السياق العامل
المتعدده الاوجه في تونس ثم نتساءل اين
سيذهب المشهد الحقيقي والسياسي في تونس
على ضوء المؤشرات والرسائل التي تطلقها
السلطات التونسيه في معالجه مثل هذه
القضايا المتعلقه بمعارضين للرئيس
[موسيقى]
انتقاميه وتزدحم بانتهاكات صارخه للقضاء
النزيه والعادي ليس اقلها محاكمه مدنيين
امام القضاء العسكري واصدار احكام في قضيه
كانت بالامس القريب من انذار القضائي
المدني هكذا علقت المعارضه التونسيه
والشخصيات حقوقيه على الاحكام التي اصدرها
القضاء العسكري على رئيس كتله ائتلاف
الكرامه سيف الدين مخلوف واخرين ينتمون
لنفس الجهه الاحكام التي شملت ايضا
المحامي المهدي جروبه فيما تعرفوا بقضيه
المطار اجججت الجدل بشان ما وصل اليه
المشهدان الحقوق والسياسي في سياق ازمه
خارقه ترزح تونس تحتها رئيس جبهه الخلاص
الوطنيه التونسيه المعارضه احمد نجيب
الشاب قالت ان حمله الاعتقالات تثبت ان
لدى السلطات اراده لحصد رؤوس قيادات
المعارضه عن طريق المحاكمات القضائيه
مضيفا انه ليس ان تتم محاكمه المدنيين
امام محاكم عسكريه في المقابل دعا الرئيس
التونسي قي السيد وفق بلاغ للرئاسه
التونسيه الى ضروره التصدي لكل المفسدين
ممن يعتقدون انهم فوق القانون حسب ما جاء
في كلامه
هذا وكاله محكمه الاستئناف العسكريه
تونسيه قد قضت بسجن نواب من كتله ائتلاف
الكرامه بالبرلمان المنحل في احكام تراوحت
بين خمسه اشهر و14 شهرا مع التنفيذ العاجل
فيما تعرفوا بقضيه المطار وتعود القضيه
الى شكوى تقدمت بها نقابات امنيه للقضاء
العسكري اتهمت فيها النواب ومرافقين لهم
باقتحام مطار تونس قرطاج عام 2001
والاعتداء على امنيين في حين اكد المتهمون
انهم كانوا يقومون بما هو في صلب مهامهم
النيابيا الرقابيه بالدفاع عن حق
المواطنين في السفر بعد منعهم منه دون حكم
القضاء كما هو مقرر في الدستوري والقانون
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من مدينه
الرفراف في ولايه بنزرت المحامي سمير ديلو
عضو هيئه الدفاع عن المتهمين في ما تعرف
بقضيه المطار ومن تونس المحامي احمد
ركروكي مساعد الامين العام لحراك ال 25 من
جويليه ومن تونس ايضا صلاح الدين الجوشي
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا بضيوف وابدا
معك السيد احمد الركنكي لافهم منك او
احاول ان نجد اجابه على السؤال المطروحه
الان في تونس كيف يتم محاكمه مدنيين في
محكمه عسكريه ان هيك عن كونهن حقوقيين
وبرلمانيين وفي قضيه كان قد بات فيها
القضاء المدني
شكرا اولا على الاستضافه مرحبا بجميع
مشاهدي قناه الجزيره اهلا وسهلا لابد من
التوضيح قبل التعليق
مرحبا
التوضيح
ان الاختصاص العسكري معلوم والاختصاص
المدني كذلك وهي مثل القانونيه تناقش داخل
الوقت الكليات وليس داخل المنابر
الاعلاميه وانا لها ياكل احترمها لذلك لن
اناقش ولكن سوف ابسط المثل القانونيه
احتراما لمهنتي كمحامي
سيدي الكريم
هناك فرق كبير بين اداء العمل المهني
كمحامي الذي يبتسي حصانه وبين العمل
السياسي وشتان بين الثراء وثريا
اولا احيي زميلي مهدي زقروبه واتمنى له ان
يكون في صحه جيده سواء قبل تنفيذ العقاب
او بعده وانا اسانده لانه ادى مهامه
اما زميلي سيف الدين مخلوف من باب الزمالك
كذلك احترمه ولكن
هو كان كعضو مجلس النواب ومكانه الطبيعي
كان يجب ان يكون تحت قبه البرلمان وليس
داخل مكان زياده
بكل هدوء الحلقه زمانها اقل من 25 دقيقه
وانا سالتك سؤال تعلق بالقضاء العسكري
والقضاء المدني ولماذا يتم
سؤالي ولك ان تجيب بكل راحه سيد احمد كيف
يتم محاكمه مدنيين امام القضاء العسكري
واتمنى ان تستضيفوني في حلقه مطوله اكثر
لتفسير لانها مثلا
اليوم حوارنا يتعلق انه رئيس قيس سعيد
يريد ان يصفي خرسهما بالقضاء العسكري
وبالتالي سوف اجيبها بعد سماع الخصوم اما
المثل الاجرائيه القانونيه فتلك ما زالت
محل تنازع وحكم غير بيت
نزل عندهم الحق في التعقيب وبعد صدور حكم
التعقيب يمكننا ان نحلل القوانين احتراما
للجهاز القضائي اعلمكم بهذا طيب وهنا اسال
ضيف السيد سمير ديلو فيما يتعلق بمحاوله
فهم هذا الاشكال المطروحه الان سواء في
ابعاده القانونيه او السياسيه في ظل
السياق
لمساله المحاكمه واصدار هذه الاحكام من
حيث الشكل من قبل القضاء العسكري
ليس ايسر من الجواب على سؤالكم ان اعتمد
المجيب قاعده الحين في ترك الحيل لان
الاختصاص معقود للقضاء المدني منذ الايام
الاولى بعد حادثه المطار وتعهد القضاء
المدني هذه تحقيق بالمكتب 20 وصل الى حكم
على المحكمه الناحيه بتونس القضاء المدني
ايضا بثلاثه اشهر سجنا النافذه ثم تم
استئناف هذا الحكم امام المحكمه
الابتدائيه بتونس وصدر حكم في 25 مايو
2022 بثلاثه اشهر مع تاجيل التمثيل وقيله
اشهر من الشهر الثالث الى شهر اجويريه لم
يتحرك القبائل العسكري ولم يضر في خلده
ابدا انا لو اي اختصاص في النظر في هذه
القضيه ولكن المباشر وبعد اربع ايام من
الانقلاب 25 جوليا يوليو 2021 فتحت
المحكمه العسكريه منتصف الليل واتخذت كل
الاجراء في كنف ساعه واحده هزمت منازل
نواب والمحامين وصدرت الاحكام دون مرافعات
في الدور الاول ثم صدرت الاحكام المحكمه
العسكريه الاستئنافيه بشكل مخالف للقانون
وزميلي يستمع اليه محكمه الاستئناف
العسكريه ليس لها ان تظهر اي حكم مكتوب
لان الاحكام التي تصدر عن المحاكم
الاستئناف تصدر قابله للتنفيذ وهناك
استثناء بالنسبه للمحاكم العسكريه ان
التعقيب يوقف التنفيذ وبالتالي فالطابع
السياسي واضح والخلفيه الكيديه لا شكر
الخلفيه اسال عنها صلاح الدين الجورشي
لماذا يتم هذا الاسقاط بين هذه الاحكام
الصادره من قبل القضاء سواء كان عسكري او
مدني وتوصف بانها محاوله لتصفيه خصوم
الرئيس قيس سعيد والرئيس قيس سيد يقول لا
احد فوق القانون
شوف يعني اصبح واضح في تونس
منذ ان تولى رئيس قيس سعيد زمام الامور
بشكل كامل على مستوى الدوله ان هناك خصومه
سياسيه وسعه النطاق
وتتعقد يوما بعد يوم بين الرئيس وسلطه 25
يوليا وبين عدد لا باس به من المعارضين له
وبالتالي هذه القريه تندرج بالضروره في
اطار هذا الصراع السياسي خاصه وان هؤلاء
الذين تمت محاكمتهم ووضعوا في داخل السجن
هم المشاكل قياده او مجموعه قياديين
اساسيين في حزب معارض همم للرئيس سعيد
وبالتالي همم اعاده المحاكمه وبهذه السرعه
التي تم انشاء اشاره اليها الاستاذ سمير
تدل بان هناك تصعيد على مستوى ادوات همم
تحكم في الساحه السياسيه وفي البلد من
خلال هذه المحاكمه خاصه وان هذه المحاكمه
وراءها رسالتان الرساله الاولى هو اا
معاقبه هؤلاء وبالتالي محاوله اخراجهم من
العمل السياسي ومن ساحه الصراع المدني ومن
جهه ثانيه فيها رساله مواجهه للمعارضين
الى قيس سعيد بانه لن يسكت وان تعتبر
معركته معهم ستستمر بقطع النظر عن اوضاع
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعي في البلد النظر عن
التحديات التي تواجه تونس اليوم وبالتالي
هي في قضيه سياسيه امتياز طيب الاستاذ
الفعل حتى الان على هذه الاحكام وما الذي
خلفته طبعا احكام الصادر عن الاحكام
العسكريه قالت الهيئه الوطنيه للمحامين
التونسيين في بيان لها انها تستاجن بشده
اصدار القضاء العسكري احكام سجن على
محامين ونشيطين
الهيئه رئيس الجمهوريه لاستبعاد محاكمه
المدنيين
امام القضاء العسكري اضافه الى ذلك حذرت
هيئه المحامين في تونس مما وصفتها بسياسه
التضييق على الحريات وندعو لمراجعه
المرسوم الرئاسي رقم 54 وهنا اسال ضيفي من
تونس المحامي احمد ركروكي في متعلق بعلق
لحتى الان هذه ليئات النقابيه التي
استهجنت هذا الفعل ودعت الى الفصل بينما
هو سياسي وعدم توريط القضاء في مثل هذه
المسائل الى اين تتجه الامور في تونس في
هذه الحاله
صديقي اولا اجيب بعد ما سمعت تفضل
الذي قال الحين في ترك الحيل
نحن لا نتحيل لا على القانون ولا على
الدين
ونحن ابناء واخلاق ودين
ثم
لولا قيس سعيد لما كان هناك ما يسمى
بائتلاف الكرامه
تونس سيف الدين مخلوف لم يكون مصنف داخل
الاتحاد مع الاتحاد العام لطلبه تونس
وبالتالي لا يمكن ان نتحدث على قياده بعد
20 وحده
الثوره الحقيقيه التي خانها الاخوان
وجيدا معقول الاخوان الذين من وراء البحار
كنت معارض الدنيا عليه ولم يكن لهم لا
ركزا ولا قولا فاتوا وسطوا على الثوره على
ثوره الزواوله على ثوره التوانسه
ويحللون فيه
وخيانتهم والله
كلاب يتحدثون رجاء نعم اي خلاف يتحدثون
لست ادري ما تنفع سي السيد احمد
لست ادري لما تنفع السيد احمد نحن في نقاش
سيد احمد
طيب انهم ليسوا لا اهلا
وسهلا
ما العلاقه بينما تقوله الان وبين سؤالي
وما قاله الضيفين قبل ذلك
ملاهي المنافقون
ياك وامر لكلمه
لا باس طبعا هذه مساحتك وهذا رايكم انه
لاسال السيد سمير دينه في ظل ما قاله
الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد بانه لا احد فوق
القانون يبدو ان الرئيس ماضي في خطواته
واجراءاته كما تتهمه المعارضه بانها كل ما
يقوم به انما هو محاوله لتصفيه الاصوات
المعادله وبالتالي الى اين يتجه الوضع
القانوني والسياسي في تونس في هذه الحاله
حسب رايك
عباره غير دقيقه لانها والله صحه للقول
بانه لا احد فوق القانون السيد قيس عيل
نفسه هو الذي فوق القانون بل هو فوق
الدستور حتى فوق الاعتبارات البسيطه التي
ترعاها الشعوب والامم منذ 48 ساعه اصدرت
محكمه تونسيه حكما بتبيعه قاضيه اتهمها
رئيس الجمهوريه بالزنامه وتعلنت في شرفها
ثم سلخها في همم الفضاء الاجتماع من طرف
انصار ال- همم الكلاب هذه عينه تبين ان
الذين يتطاولون على القانون ليسوا
المعارضين نحن احترمنا القانون وتواجهنا
الى المحاكم الدفاع عن زملائنا والدفاع عن
المحامين ونحن لا نفرق بين الاستاذ سيف
الدين مخلوف الاستاذ مجدي تجربه فكلاهما
محامي شريف مدافع عن الحقوق والحريات
يدافع عن ارائه ويجب احترامها
لكن هذه السلطه تعمل الى خرق كل المقتضيات
القانونيه حتى السلطه في عهد زين العابدين
بن علي قبل الثوره كانت تحترم بعض
الاجراءات لذره الرماد على العيون ولكن
هذه السلطه فشلت في كل شيء كل شيءات التي
فتحتها فشلت حتى في تنفيق القضايا بشكل
يجوز على الملحدين والمتابعين فوصلنا الى
هذه المهزله انتقلنا من الفضيحه الى العبث
الى الجنون القانوني والجنون القضائي
اصبحت الاحكام القضائيه في بعض مراحلها
مجرد اقسااء بصبغه قانونيه لعمليات اختطاف
للمعارض
من اصدرت هذا هذا الحكم هي ايضا هيئه
قضائيه سواء كانت عسكريه او مدنيه ولكنها
هيئه قضائيه وبالتالي لماذا هذا التشكيك
وهذا الطرح
هو الحقيقه من من وجهه
نظري اعتقد بانه الرئيس قيس سعيد قد ارتكب
في اطار صراعي السياسي المفتوح ضد خصومه
وكذلك في اطار سياق اعاده ترتيب الاوضاع
في تونس كما يؤمن بذلك هذه الاخطاء تتمثل
اولا في ادخال العسكر والجيش في العمليه
السياسيه بمعنى ان المحاكم العسكري لها
خصوصياتها ولها ادواتها
وبالتالي ايقاف ومحاكمه خصوم سياسيين همم
امام المحاكم العسكريه ليس في قضيه واحده
قضايا تتواتر بسرعه جعل مش فقدت الطبقه
السياسيه مش فقدت الحقوقيين ولكن حتى على
المستوى الدولي هناك لمثل هذا اللجوء
المتواصل همم في هذا السياق اي اا تنشيط
بشكل مكثف للمحاكم العسكريه الامر الثاني
اللي هو اثار الكثير من الالتباس والكثير
من الرفض وهو المرسوم 54 والذي حاربه
الاعلاميون الان يمس تقريبا معظم الشرائح
ومعظم عناصر النخبه همم في تونس والتي اا
اذنته معظم الاتراك بما في ذلك الطرف كانت
قريبه من الرئيس قيس سعيد وكانت مستانده
له لانه همم ايجاد قانون يمكن ان يحاكمك
على اي قول وعلى اي صيغه وعلى اي جمله
ممكن ان تقوده انت في الفيسبوك او في نفس
او في تصريح هذا يشكل خطرا يهدد حريه
التعبير اللي هي من اهم حريات التي جاءت
بها الثوره التونسيه
ما الذي يضيفه هذا المشد القانوني
والحقوقي اللي همم المشهد الكامل للصوره
الكامله في تونس
انا يبدولي انا الاوضاع الان في تونس تتجه
الى تعميق الاشتباك بين السلطه وبين
خصومها وخصومها يزدادون اتسان واننا سنشهد
ربما هذه السنه يعني من محاكمات عديده في
هذا الاتجاه وهو ما سيضع تونس مع انها
كمثال
للانتقاد من قبل المنظمات الدوليه
والمنظمات الحقوقيه وهذا بكله لن يساعد
تونس على انها تستعيد وضحه الطبيعي تحاول
ان تحل مشاكلها الاقتصاديه وتبحث عن
تمويلات جديه من طرف مؤسسات التمويل وخاصه
فكره ثوره فكره الحريه فكره القيم
الاساسيه التي دافع عنها التونسيون في
الجيش تصبح الان مهدده وحوله نقاط استفهام
عديده وكان صوره تونس تتغير كثيرا من مثل
هذه المحاكمات هذه الاجراءات هل انت مع
فكره ان يحاكما مدنيون امام القضاء
العسكري
لكل اختصاصه وتبقى المحاكم المدنيه مختصه
بمحاكمه المدنيين والعسكريين كذلك
حقوقي قبل ان اكون كسياسي يدافع واسلميت
انه لا دخل في المدني في السياسه ولا دخل
المدني في العسكري انا مع الاستاذ الكريم
ربي يفرج كربه المهدي زقروبه لانه ذهب الى
المطار كما سبق وقلت لاداء مهامه اما من
اشتغل بالسياسه فلا فليتحمل مسؤوليته وهذا
قد اصدر بيانه مجلس الهيئه في سواء في عهد
سيدنا العميد ابراهيم بودرباله وكذلك في
سيد العميد حاتم وبذلك وكذلك جمعيه الشباب
على راسها الاستاذ طارق الحركات وانا
اتمسك مهني بما ذهب اليه زملائي مع ذكر ان
اعلام نيابتي قد قدم في محاكمه الاستاذ
مهدي الزغروبه وانا استنيت عليك حققه لذلك
لا يريد انه نلوث الطيبه بالخبيث ونستميت
في الدفاع عن الحقوق والحريات ما دمنا
احياء في هذا البلاد
بعد اصوات المحامين كتبت وعلقت اليوم همم
للمواطنين لا تحاول ان تتوكل عن مواطنين
قد تصبحوا انتم المتهمون وتدخلون السجن ما
الذي يمكن قوله امام هذا الصوره وهذا
المشهد
الحريه تحتاج تضحيات تحتاج قناعات نحن
نواجه هذه
مواجهه مدنيه سلميه ولكن اذا اردت من خلال
هذه المحاكمات تخوين في المعاردين
والمحامين والنواب فهم لا يخافون واذا
اراد التخويف بهم فمن خلفهم لا يخافون
ايضا
شكرا جزيلا لك من مدينه رفراف في ولايه
بنزرت المحامي سمير ديلو عضو هيئه الدفاع
عن المتهمين فيما تعرف بقضيه المطار وكذلك
الشكر لضيف من تونس المحامي احمد ركروكي
مساعد الامين العام لحراك 25 جويليه وكذلك
لضيفي من تونس صلاح الدين جورج كاتب
والمحلل السياسي
انه لا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء باذن الله
[موسيقى]